le questionnaire du cirque cette
question comme les 7 doigts de la main
c'est indolore
vous êtes prêts j'ai bien fait de vous
êtes un film qui vous a donné envie de
faire du cinéma
je fais comme si je réfléchissais ou
comme si on m'avait envoyé les questions
faites comme si vous réfléchissez mais
un peu très court retour vers le futur
hockey ouais parce que j'étais ado en
voyant ça et je me suis dit waouh c'est
c'est super ce qu'on peut faire en
racontant une histoire quand on a les
moyens on peut partir dans le passé
revenir à voir une delorean enfin
d'avoir des ddd skateboard qui touchent
pas le sol écrire ce qu'on veut quoi
avec un professeur fou c'était tellement
coloré que j'ai adoré je me suis dit oh
j'adorerais faire du cinéma un film que
vous adorez mais en secret à merde
qu'est ce que j'avais répondu à cela
quand on me l'avait envoyé qu'un jour le
grinch ouais alors pourquoi le grinch
pourquoi tu ris vous rien ben vous
moquez pas du tout j'en attends
attention parce qu'elles jugent
effectivement le jugeant de bon sens
jugé qu ce regard pourquoi le gris le
grinch performance de jim carrey ouais
renault voire deux à la caméra un conte
qui raconte quelque chose qui me parlent
compte que je regardais avec mes enfants
quand il était petit et quand moi
j'étais petit dans ma tête aussi du coup
vraiment c'est un truc qui me parle
c'est hyper drôle et ses bo de films
récents qui vous a fait le plus de bien
moi daniel blake way de ken loach palme
d'or à cannes
qu'est ce qui vous frappe dans ce film
l'humanité du truc sans la vulgarité en
fait sans être vulgairement humain sans
montrer grossièrement qu'il faut tendre
la main à l'autre c'est une histoire
simple c'est seul génie tine fait ça un
peu avec or là je trouve maintenant je
n'ai pas préparé ça le fait dans une
journée de
lieven denys guévin des décennies c'est
le quotidien enfin un truc très très
simple on rentre dans le détail d'un
quotidien et on comprend que c'est
horrible
sans faire des ondes grossier quoi sur
l'horreur un acteur ou une actrice qui
vous font aller au cinéma alors pas
forcément pour des réseaux
cinématographique
je comprends pas bien la question parce
qu'un acteur pour moi ça forcément déjà
cinématographique ça va être pour des
raisons sexuelle ah ouais carrément
disons le un acteur ou une actrice porno
alors vraiment à peu alors je pensais
pas que cette interview allait prendre
ce tournant la main c'est vous qui m'ont
envoyé vers la caisse non j'adore tom
cruise - tom cruise tout ce qui fait ça
veut dire que vous allez voir
systématiquement tout est en cause et
oui parce que ce mec est producteur
aussi donc fait des choix et visiblement
se trompent quasiment jamais quoi dans
ses choix c'est assez rare également
souligné quoi frédéric mercier qui a dès
le collège c'est mon frère et astier
aussi laurent lafitte asile dans lequel
vous aimeriez vivre
lalonde los angeles clean sympa ça dort
aux 9,3 qu'ils aiment bien la hauteur à
l'acteur coréalisateur et aux
spectateurs que je parle
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez voir plus
souvent au cinéma des comédies anglaises
ça me manquait que le ton anglais mans
qui pensait à quoi je pense en
particulier à des séries aujourd'hui
série anglaise bons offices forcément
changé ma vie terme de
d'écriture comique et catastrophe là en
ce moment et c'est une série anglaise
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre l'écriture et les plus
chaque chaque phrase chaque punchline
est drôle mais en même temps sous-entend
tout un tas de choses et et une culture
incroyable et en même temps c'est bien
fabriqué c'est très humain ils sont
encore une fois en avance et enfin eric
un film que vous aimeriez affirme plutôt
à envoyer ses rêves ou trouble est en
fait un film à envoyer dans l'espace
pour présenter l'humanité aux aliens
mine de réfléchir le nouveau de rudi
rosenberg a way aulas vraiment
s'attendait à tout sauf ça et alors non
c'est bien mais ce fait quoi mais pour
voir et non pas le genre de la maison
mais pourquoi ce film là parce que je le
trouve formidable je le trouve très
humain et quitte à dire qui nous sommes
aux extraterrestres bah voilà le nouveau
fait partie de ces films qui racontent
qu'ils sont les hommes les hommes
préadolescents soit puisqu'ils ont entre
10 et 12 ans mais il ya tout yann l
levis humains il ya la beauté
il ya l'amour il ya tout dedans le
nouveau est envoyé aux aliens merci
beaucoup eric une dernière question
quand même pour finir quel film que vous
avez mais aussi jean renverrait
peut-être aussi à nous les petites
anglaises à benny hill comme celle
d'israël seront vraiment débile on va
les attaquer en fait on est moins con
que ça tu vois le sait bien le film que
vous avez le plus envie de faire c'est
essayer mais c'est pas mal je ne lui en
veux tu que vous serez le plus envie de
voir cet été je sais pas s'il sort cet
été
faudrait que tu demandes à ton frère age
of tomorrow 2 je me pose rassure toi en
se séparant débrouiller merde quand même
ici impossible en attendant ouais mais
edge of tomorrow moi ça me laisse encore
de date de sortie et rythmé mission
impossible
évidemment on ira voir mission
impossible on ira tous ensemble au caire
et vous on se bloque une date à l'est
alors à aa